what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video today I want to
talk about Arya Stark and some of the
biggest potential reunions she may have
this season Arya Stark is one of those
characters that have been all over
Westeros she has met so many different
cool and interesting characters along
the way and now that she is back in
Westeros the chances of her running into
some of these characters again are very
high so let's go over some of the ones
that US fans really want to see and
comment down below and let me know which
one you are looking forward to the most
Arya Stark is currently at the twins
which is where we last saw her during
the season six finale when she got
vengeance for her family when she killed
two of water phrase sons and then she
slipped water phrase through when the
new season begins Arya will most likely
still be there killing some more of the
phrase and hopefully freeing her uncle
Edmure but the big question is will she
head straight home next HBO has only
released a few photos in quick scenes of
Arya Stark and from what we've seen it
appears that Arya will still be in the
Riverlands area for a while before she
heads home in the new photos it doesn't
look like she is that far north just yet
there is some snow on the ground but
there isn't any snow on her hair or on
her clothes so I'm thinking she may
spend a few episodes in this area before
she actually makes it back to Winterfell
and if this is the case then she will
most likely run into some old friends
and foes along the way I know most of us
have been patiently waiting to see the
reunion with Nymeria we haven't seen
Arya's dire wolf since the first season
and as far as I know they haven't
mentioned Nymeria sense but her dire
wolf is definitely still alive in the
books not only is she still alive but
she actually has a wolf pack running
wild with her aurilla dreams about this
all the time and she also wargs into her
in the books
Nymeria has been roaming the Riverlands
ever since Arya had to scare her away
because Cersei would have most likely
had Nymeria killed for biting Joffrey so
I think this would be the perfect time
to reintroduce 9 area to the plot Arya
is back in Westeros and she's in the
Riverlands which is the same general
location Nymeria would be in I think we
will see her again this season and they
may have even teased this in the trailer
if you remember the first trailer there
was a quick scene of Orion trying to
start a fire but what's interesting
about this scene is how low the camera
actually is area is crouched down to the
ground and she is building this fire but
the view the camera gives us of this is
still at the eye level which means this
could be the POV from an animal watching
reo so I'm hoping this is 9 area looking
at Aria and we are seeing this through
her eyes
there is another scene of Aria in the
trailer that could also be seen as a POV
through Nami areas eyes as Aria is
riding through the woods on our horse
here do you notice how the camera has a
weird glare or tint to the lens almost
like there is a smudge on the camera
this is very similar to what it looks
like when you're looking through the
direwolf sighs back in season 3 brain
stark works into the direwolf while John
is outside fighting the wildling
and when brain does this they show us a
quick scene looking through the eyes of
the direwolf and it has a very similar
filter or tint to the lens as we see
here with aria
so this could be us looking through the
eyes of 9 area in these scenes with aria
in the trailers but let me know in the
comments if you agree with this the next
possible reunion that I know we've all
been waiting for is what the Hound I
don't know about you but Arya and the
Hound were one of my favorite duo's in
the entire show
damn near every scene they had together
was great and now that aria is so much
more grown up this combo has even more
potential now to be great as of right
now the Hound is with the Brotherhood
without banners and they aren't too far
from where Aria is right now based on
the official HBO photos it appears that
the Hound and the Brotherhood will be
heading north which is exactly where
aureus Stark is going to be heading next
there is a very good chance that the
Hound and the Brotherhood stop at
Winterfell on their way to the wall
after watching the second trailer it's
obvious that the Hound and the
Brotherhood without banners will go
north of the wall with Jon Snow and
several other characters so it's
possible the Hound stops at Winterfell
to meet John or they could stop there to
get torment because we know torment goes
north of the wall too and I think if the
Hound ends up stopping at Winterfell he
may reunite with Arya there but they
could also meet up along the way they
may even stop at an end to get warm and
to get some food they could bump into
each other there not to mention Arya
could run into hot pie here too we have
seen a few
of Oriya indoors somewhere which most
people think is that some kind of tavern
or n and if that's the case it could be
the same place we last saw hot pie the
Brotherhood without banners have stopped
there before this could end up being a
very cool scene but there is something
that could make this reunion very
interesting the hound is currently with
beric Dondarrion and Thoris of Mir which
are the same men that sold Gendry to
Melisandre aurilla had both of them on
her list so I wonder what's going to
happen if she sees them again - I think
barek and Thoros will dine or for the
wall but we could still get a
confrontation with them in Arya if she
runs into them before they make it to
the wall I don't think she's going to
forget how they just discarded Gendry
for some gold
knowing Melisandre had some fucked-up
intentions for Gendry and speaking of
Melisandre this is another reunion
people really want to see Melisandre is
definitely still one Orias list for
taking entry away Melisandre also told
Arya that they would see each other
again
and ever since Melisandre said this to
Arya I've been waiting for this day to
come so I'm hoping we see this soon last
time we saw Melisandre she was leaving
Winterfell after Jon exiled her from the
north for sacrificing princess Shireen
Melisandre is going to be heading south
to Dragonstone and she's most likely
going to travel right through the area
Arya Starks going to be at in the
trailer we did see Melisandre at
Dragonstone so we know she does go south
but we'll horror and Arya cross paths
once again as Arya heads north and she
head south but I have to assume Arya
doesn't kill her if they do meet because
Melisandre does make it to Dragonstone
unless that's Arya wearing her face but
I highly doubt it what do you think is
going to happen when these two meet
again do you think Arya is going to kill
her let me know what you think about
this potential explosive reunion but
there's another one I want to talk about
what's his little finger and Arya
meeting again Littlefinger is still at
Winterfell and Arya is going to be on
her way there Orion knows little finger
and Tywin were allies back when Tywin
and her brother raw brat war Arya may
get home and expose Littlefinger's
treachery that should lead to his death
most of us know little fingers time is
running out the only question is who's
going to be the one to fully expose him
and sentence him to death and then
execute him
could it be Aria and if the Hound does
show up I wonder fell he could also
possibly expose Littlefinger as well the
hound was there when Littlefinger put
the knife to Ned's throat I think the
helm would be more than willing to tell
Arya and Sansa what he had seen
when Arya gets home she's most likely
going to be the catalyst for little
thinker's downfall this is one reunion
that I'm dying to see Arya is on a crash
course with so many interesting
characters that could have some very
interesting results not only did arias
training with the faceless man teach her
how to kill but it also taught her how
to spot a liar and that's bad news for
Littlefinger bran Stark is also going to
be at Winterfell when he may have some
flashbacks of every single time
Littlefinger betrayed two Starks if I
were a little finger I would get the
hell out of Winterfell ASAP but there's
something else that oh when I ask all of
you do you think Arya and Jack and Hegar
is ever going to cross paths again do
you think Arya is going to receive any
kind of blowback for just walking away
from the faceless men like she did I've
been asked this question a bunch of
times but I'm wondering what everyone
else has to say about this some people
say Arya is going to be punished and
some people say nothing's going to
happen at all but it would be a pretty
big deal if they did meet again but I'm
not so sure Jack and would kill her now
I know he did allow the waste to hunt
her down but it was pretty obvious that
Jack and did take a liking to Arya it
was like they were destined to meet each
other almost as if she was handpicked to
be recruited by the faceless men I do
have a feeling we will see Jack in
Agoura again but it might actually be at
the Citadel they probably don't have
enough time to do the whole book plot at
the Citadel but they could give us a
taste and if they do Jack ins role isn't
quite finished yet but I'm not going to
hold my breath on that one but I'm also
really hoping that Aria and Gendry meet
again too
they were obviously very close when they
were together but as far as Arya knows
ginjury could be dead right now
aurilla did know Melisandre had evil
intentions for ginjury an aria hasn't
seen ginjury since Melisandre had him
courted away and Orion ever got word
that Davos helped him escape it would be
cool if she got that closure knowing
that her close friend is still alive
Gendry could potentially be the last
living person that has baratheon blood
right now so unless they introduce
another Baratheon in the Stormlands
like that then we need Gendry to come
back and be legitimized as a Baratheon
so the house doesn't go extinct then we
need aria and ginjury to reunite get
married then go west of Westeros
together I know that's what's we're
thinking but damn it can a man dream
Game of Thrones can't have a bad ending
for every damn character someone needs
to live happily ever after right using
this as an opinion isn't anything
attention as [ __ ] you Ramsey what do you
know you little prick all right folks
let's do one more the last but certainly
not the least the mega reunion aka the
stark reunion this is what the people
want so this is what the people will get
we need aria brand Sansa and John all
together at least one more time before
any more of them start dying
just one last scene of the Starks
together happy at Winterfell
at least give us that before the damn
night King and his minions arrives John
and songs are there together right now
and brain is heading that way brain is
going to make it to the godswood
I just hope John and songs are both
there when he arrives but John will most
likely be gone when he gets there
because you know how they do us they
will never give us that satisfaction
immediately the big stark reunion is
going to be teased and teased and as
soon as John leaves
that's when Brandon Arya is probably
going to show up John is going to be all
over the place this season and I'm
afraid John isn't going to make it back
to Winterfell until season eight John
might be north of the wall in this
season 7 finale and if he's not north of
the wall he's probably going to head
straight back down south when he escapes
the night King's attack but I hope I'm
wrong
I hope John makes a pit stop back at
Winterfell while Brandon Oriya is there
but what do you all think do you think
we're going to get the full stark
reunion this season let me know down in
the comment section thanks for stopping
by and watching a video I really
appreciate that I'm looking forward to
seeing some of the feedback on this
video I want to know what you all want
to see the most and I got to thank my
supporters on patreon - the donations
have helped me and the channel
tremendously I love you all and I'll see
you down below bye